[Musique]
jacqueline nous voilà revenus dans le
studio que l'on appelle le studio de
complément vous savez nous avons reçu
beaucoup de questions qui vous concerne
et une petite fille particulièrement
voudrais savoir si vous aimez mieux
présenter les émissions l'après-midi ou
le soir
ah voilà une question assez délicate
parce que je dois dire que sur le plan
personnel cela met absolument égal
toutefois rue avec une petite préférence
pour le soir quand même parce que sur le
plan artistique que c'est plus
intéressant nous avons des émissions
plus grande à porter toutes les
conséquences si je me trouvais ainsi est
vraiment c'est un plus grand plaisir
mais de l'autre côté et bien voyez vous
il n'y a absolument aucune différence
puisque nous sommes dans un studio vous
y êtes vous pouvez le constater il n'y a
absolument aucune ouverture aucune
fenêtre
il n'y a pas la lumière du jour par
conséquent nous sommes deux jours sous
celle des projecteurs et on ne peut pas
différencier midi de minuit ce cela il
ya cependant une après midi que vous
aimez particulièrement à cela bien sûr
pierre et c'est celle du jeudi nous
sommes j'ai dit vous savez que là
vraiment c'est un très très grand
plaisir pour moi d'accueillir tous nos
petits téléspectateurs de tous les coins
de france est vraiment c'est mon
émission préférée je viens voyez-vous
tous les jeunes téléspectateurs voient
en ce moment le studio choses qu'ils ne
connaissent guère car ils vous voient
dans le studio mais ne savent pas ce
qu'il y autour de vous qu'est ce que
c'est que cette table où il ya votre sac
et des journaux a alors là c'est la
table où nous nous pouvons nous pouvons
faire un petit raccord brouillé mode
l'art c'est notre petit tiroir à manille
là il ya le poudrier il y a le
fanta le rouge à lèvres aussi bros
peigne enfin tout ce qui nous permet de
nous mettre en beauté avant d'apparaître
mais vous n'avez guère besoin afin que
celle-ci crcc deux choses ces deux
espèces de tuyaux de poêle qui a devancé
les microbes est trop gentil pour nos
micros 1113 esthétique
oui non mais c'est très curieux comment
ils sont des choses auxquelles on n'est
pas habitué dans la pluie devrait cesser
la grande feuille que vous avez sur
cette table devant vous alors cette
grande faille c est ce que nous appelons
le conducteur des émissions voyez-vous
avant de présenter nos émissions nous
remettre ce papier sur lequel sont
indiquées tous les horaires des
émissions que nous aurons à présenter
aussi les noms des réalisateurs et j'ai
employé le terme horreur et c'est
vraiment ça voyez vous on est un petit
peu comme un chef de quart qui doit
connaître par coeur les horaires de ces
prêts est à nous et évidemment de le
présenter à nos téléspectateurs d'une
façon agréable
dites moi qu'est ce que c'est la grosse
boîte qui a sur la table devant condom
assez de bottes lacées notre interphone
alors voyez vous il ya des tops petit
bouton il cela nous permet de
communiquer avec la régie finale de
poser des questions au moment d'une
émission ou au moment d'une chose
inattendue s'il faut par exemple si il a
été décidé qu'un internaute doit passer
entre deux émissions nous demandons
quelle sera cette interlude et ça permet
aussi aux gens de la régie finale de
communiquer avec nous nous recevons les
arbres pour vous les entendez par ou
bien haut parleur mais oui il ya ou par
les retourner vos pierres vous allez
voir là bas avec vous cette grande voix
mme lurie avec un trou dans le mur et à
côté je vois d'ailleurs une chose forte
intéressante j'aperçois la pendule de
l'horloge parlante et vous la
reconnaissez
il y en a mais on marche avant les
émissions à c est aussi un rêve
d'exactement sur l'horloge pas
exactement à nos opérateurs est en
contact avec l'horloge parlante reçoit
l'heure exacte et l'indic sur la pendule
et il ya encore en studio des
projecteurs bien sûr et un récepteur sur
lequel vous contrôlez votre image cet
examen hier parce que voyez vous je
crois que c'est amusant de signaler nous
n'avons pas de cameraman ou nous cadrons
nous mêmes
alors nous sommes sur notre petit
cierges et en regardant cette image de
contrôle et bien nous voyons
exactement où nous devons nous placer si
nous sommes tombés à droite comme à
gauche et en général nous essayons de
respecter le centre est effectivement
cette caméra qui est devant vous la est
une caméra tout seul sans caméraman et
bien maintenant chers jacqueline je
crois qu'il est temps de nous quitter
nous allons vous retrouver dans un
instant car notre émission arrive à sa
fin je n'aurais rssi ainsi que marianne
de seine et catherine langeais d'avoir
répondu si gentiment à nos questions il
ne nous reste plus maintenant qu'à
passer notre générique de fin eh bien
c'est ce que nous allons faire au revoir
pierre a tout de suite a tout de suite
c'est vrai
[Musique]